hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm Kat Alvarado when cats on the
channel we got a watch something that is
scary related in some way because that's
what homegirl and I do yes it's my
signature we usually watch from our
friends from top five unknowns a
fantastic channel they're great people
and they have this video here that I
think is perfectly suitable 5 scariest
Mexican urban legends with the curse of
yeah Haruna La Llorona coming out this
month no no and that's how you say it ok
and Kat is some kind of Spanish yeah I'm
so South Mexican there you go Nicaraguan
I'm Nicaraguan that's what it is I
figured this is perfectly suited for
what we normally do at hey transition
cat has a podcast called villains of
history tell him about a cat villains of
history is about the worst people in
history it's a podcast spreg was on it
he was actually on the first episode he
popped my podcast cherry there are so
many really funny and educational
informative episodes so listen to them
while you drive do chores whatever
they're great and yeah or while you're
popping cherries right please no
murdering of real children
just that's the one thing I can't that's
their limit when you were younger it is
very likely betting parents told you
stories of mythical creatures like the
boogeyman preying on that children in
order to steer you straight but do these
stories compared to these Mexican urban
legends welcome to five the most
terrifying Mexican urban legends number
five
probably the most well-known line
American the Huckle creature is a cheap
camera the name literally translates to
go sucker as it is not to go around suck
the blood of livestock those calmly
goats this creature was first reported
to be seen Porto Rico in March of 1995
this first reported sight Eagles were
discovered that completely blood drained
the chupacabra was also seen again that
year only a few months later where
around 150 animals were allegedly killed
after these bizarre attacks were
published in Puerto Rico
more and more attacks reported but this
time not just in Puerto Rico but all
over the South American continent there
are many different descriptions of what
the chupacabra really looks like the
most popular being left killing creature
with green skin and red eyes it is also
said that a giant spike keep going down
his back dinosaur okay
just like the West a nice story of the
hoagie man
alcohol's alleged used to scare kids
into behaving themselves
awfully compared to the devil who will
look at other children I misbehave and
would go to their homes once I'll KOCO
got did a child it is said that a you
either eat them as a whole or bring the
child to a very scary place far away
from home this legend originated in
Portugal and took the form of a ghost
with a pumpkin head the story behind
this legend is that a man who suffered
from tuberculosis was extremely
desperate in finding a cure he was so
desperate that he went to a native
healer to get a cure this healer told
him that he must drink the blood of a
child in order to be cured so now he
roams the street in search of
misbehaving children as this legend
spread across the South American world
I'll propose if he has changed he is not
described to be a shape-shifting being
that is very ugly and scary to look at
some say that he even takes the shape of
a shadow on the wall that should we be
there he even hides anywhere in a
child's room from behind the curtains
under the bed other people say he's
about the size of the fairy and has
piercing red eyes the story of El Coco
are commonly wide variety there he
didn't see a ring llama Rona she's such
a part of the legend
have been many movies and songs based on
coming out beautiful her husband she
became very depressed about it that she
drive herself as Bob said has its gates
a nurse that she is not allowed to enter
until she finds her children Diana so
now many guests weeping ghost is forced
to wander the rivers and canals at night
and search for her children it is said
that idea when I will kidnap children
that resembles hers and beg them for
forgiveness
she then trounced them again in order to
go to heaven but never nice it was
rejecting all at once Street at night
and hear her weeping you're marked for
death so don't even bother running
number two there ever tried also known
as the evildoer is an evil demon that is
known to be scarier than the devil
himself Jill stayed leave at night at
dark intersection spawn isolated rules
and wait for the lonely traveler to
cross paths with her mama how would I
change the shapes and sizes constantly
and rapidly she starts off as a large
black blob with mass if you encountered
I'm alla hold up Jill do her best to
literally drive you insane to death when
the time is right to rush eternity to
target and strangle them most people
refused to talk about this evil demon
and fear of course special will be
finding them others say that she takes
the shape of an evil old woman this
woman works all black and floats along
the side of the road also it is
important to know that this woman is a
death omen so if you spot her at any
intersection it is certain that either
you or someone you know
number look out for old woman got it as
Seaborn Act which translates to whisper
in English as a tall thin ghost that is
known as the death omen his story starts
off as man being a very spoiled child
one day this boy wanted to eat venison
for dinner so he sent his father to go
hunt for son his father was seeking
father only to find an empty hand the
boy was so furious at his father that he
proceeded by killing him
the boy then cuts up his father to
pieces and brings it home for dinner his
mother then noticed that the meat didn't
resemble venison at all and that in fact
it was a husband's body she cursed her
son for eternity and not the boy's
grandfather to tradition and sent dogs
out to hunt him the boy got rooms to
countryside searching for his next
victim you will know if you're his next
victim by eminent whistle if you hear
his whistle from up close
grew safe but if you hear it from far
away then your next thanks again to
everyone for watching this video if you
enjoyed it give it a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to us for more
updates
wow that last one had some serious
control over his parents yeah man if I
had that level of control over my mom oh
boy
the amount of times I've asked her to
pick up a very specific peanut butter
for me at Trader Joe's and she I don't
like this the creamy I don't want the
crunchy and mad time she's brought back
creamy she be hacked up so okay here's
my take just want to say the chupacabra
haunted my childhood really yeah I
totally heard of that one my mind will
go like this
who is that a kid it's all kind of blur
for me okay the chupacabra was the
beginning that was the creature that
sounded like a dinosaur and he sucked
all the blood out oh yeah yeah the goats
the goats go killer yeah go killer yeah
that came out and I remember it came out
in the mid 90s and I was
like little little little the legend the
legend came out and then he knows about
it
came out oh it was on the Spanish news
channels and people were like oh my god
it's real oh I thought this was like
around for decades
no the chupacabra is a new one and
that's why it's so weird
hmm and scary and why every time I went
outside when I was a kid if it was dark
like going from the car to the house
yeah I'd always be like is the
chupacabra gonna get me is it gonna get
me I think it's gonna get me oh oh man
I feel that way about women in general
so what do you think La Llorona is so
popular like she has if there's a movie
coming out about her now when I would go
to Halloween Horror Nights sometimes
they'd have a maze dedicated to her what
do you think that specific urban legend
has really struck a chord I think it
struck a chord because it's just so
freaky creepy a and B I bet people have
actually heard it you oh so you think
it's real yeah
there's a reason why these stories go on
okay here's my theory about a lot of
Latin American culture if you follow
literature especially Spanish literature
at all I do very religiously I might add
you might be aware of genre called
magical realism which is magical magical
real magical okay okay which is very
popular in Latin American writing okay
and my person believed as someone who is
Nicaraguan has visited Nicaragua has
family there have I've talked to my
family I realized that everybody in
Nicaragua and maybe by extension Mexico
and all Latin America we've all got
stories of the paranormal
okay and I wonder if that's what feeds
into magical realism being such a
popular way of seeing the world in a way
because we don't create entire different
worlds like you know Harry Potter or a
Star Wars it'll be a very ordinary story
and then they'll be like a magical loaf
of bread and alright I know you're
saying I give you are saying coming back
to my
yeah going back to La Llorona yeah well
do you think the maternal element has
something to do with it too like a
mother turning on the children
definitely which probably does happen in
real life I mean we've heard of stories
but one lady who drowned all her kids in
the car oh yeah plenty of stories of
like parents who killed her so okay so I
feel like there's something a little bit
easier to latch onto there yeah yeah
sorry for my tangent alert no no it's
great
Oh check out our podcast about villains
of history guys but yeah there's a lot
of women who drown their kids there's
actually a video you can find a woman
drowning her kids
drives her van like into the ocean and
the sky pulls his car over he's like
filming the whole thing he runs out of
his car and goes to try and get the kids
out of the car as she's driving her van
into the water at the beach he's a trip
and they save all the kids
it's a crazy video but we actually have
one in Nicaragua we have one called
llama Juana she's a little bit like
lemon I wore that one okay where she
kind of pops up on the road the story of
Lamech Juana is that she was this native
woman she was a native Prince as a son
of it the son the daughter of the chief
and then one of the conquistadors
fell in love with her and or she fell in
love with a conquistador and her father
had hidden his gold away so that the
Spanish wouldn't take it and the only
person he had told where it was was his
daughter the princess so she gets
pregnant and she does I said tell the
conquistador where the gold is she shows
him where it is he kills her mmm
and takes all the gold so she now haunts
men in Nicaragua and my grandfather has
seen her and my uncle's have seen her
what have you I have not well then how
do we know it's real cat maybe it's the
bedtime story to scare you before he
went to sleep good like me how my mom
would tell me Jesus Christ is gonna kill
you in my sleep Oh
is not accurate hey I grew up Catholic I
don't what the Bible says Jesus will
kill you if you don't donate to the
church that is exactly how I made to
this point in the video feel free to
second that opinion back me up here
which well that's some fascinating [ __ ]
everybody but if you know that was scary
that was that was terrifying goddamn I
wasn't expecting you to come here and be
like yeah I actually believe I don't
believe a lot of weird things but when
it comes to ghost stories especially
Latin American ones
I don't believe something until the
person I'm would believe who then I'm
like oh maybe it is real I just a second
it experienced paranormal stuff I've
experienced paranormal stuff uh-huh yeah
care to share it no yeah no I believe I
shared on another video with you and you
completely logically broke down how I
was stupid cuz I do believe in ghosts
but then anytime someone tells me a
ghost story I'm like and and that's why
I'm not gonna try to explore that here
well these were all fasting I know it's
a common theme with family being
involved in a lot of these old people
who are apparently terrifying
[ __ ] scary old people and his
Mexican he's scared of the guy next door
exactly old people are naturally scary I
call it ageism call facts whatever you
want to call guys you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification ballot follow Kat Alvarado
on social media and check out her
villains of history podcast and so many
wonderful wonderful stuff really funny
and really educational her best episode
was the one she did with me I've heard
them all Oh twice and we'll see you guys
soon thanks all five unknowns they years